vous avez peut-être déjà entendu parler
de ces sites coquins qui proposent de
regarder des femmes ou des hommes se
dénuder et s'exposer devant leur caméra
dans des pratiques sexuelles contre
rémunération vendre des photos genre des
petites vidéos et puis des gens
s'abonnent pour me soutenir voilà
certaines associations catholiques ont
voulu poursuivre ces sites de gaming
pour prostitution aggraver la peau de
cassation estimée que c'est pratique ne
pouvaient pas s'apparenter à de la
prostitution le sexe virtuelle ne rentre
donc pas dans l'arrêté de 1996 qui
stipule clairement la prostitution
consiste à se prêter moyennant une
rémunération à des contacts physiques de
quelques natures qu'ils soient afin de
satisfaire les besoins sexuels d'autrui
les game girls ou camboys ne sont donc
pas répréhensibles vis-à-vis de la loi
puisqu'ils n'ont pas de contact physique
avec leurs clients Bernard va donc
pouvoir retourner tranquillement se
faire plaisir
je veux faire l'amour
[Applaudissements]
alors en fait c'est considéré comme de
la pornographie tout simplement on peut
pas dire que c'est pas de la
prostitution à partir du moment où on
vend son corps c'est de la prostitution
la seule chose c'est que la loi en fait
n'est plus adaptée à l'époque c'est
qu'on est en 2021 à l'époque où cette
loi a été écrite elle était pas le web
il y avait pas tout ça donc forcément
c'est marqué rapprochement physique mais
pour moi il devrait mettre ça à jour
parce que oui c'est de la prostitution
quand on vend son temps
une stripteaseuse ou une effeuilleuse ce
sont des prostituées
une actrice de film pour Adulte
pas elle se met pas le droit
c'est ne compare pas ça c'est de l'art
c'est des filles c'est ça n'a rien à
voir
on veut pas comparer des filles qui qui
c'est
de là
qui se touchent qui font des des trucs
sexuels et qui se font payer pour
exciter des gens non ça c'est la
possibilité
de devant la caméra
je comprends je comprends que vous soyez
intéressé par le participe
passé cette journée il doit passer sa
journée devant qui suit ce genre de
choses moi je découvre
c'est un métier qui consiste à se filmer
et s'exposer sur Internet dans des
pratiques sexuelles contre rémunération
des pratiques sexuelles rémunération
a dit que non
si tous les réseaux sociaux comme on
vend des photos dénudées contre de
l'argent il y a de plus en plus de gens
que ça moi ce qui fait peur c'est que
justement parce qu'il n'y a pas cette
barrière physique qui est franchie les
jeunes ont de plus en plus la tentation
des les hommes ou des jeunes femmes de
faire de l'argent facile mais en réalité
c'est extrêmement dangereux déjà parce
que souvent au début on se pose des
limites on se dit je vais montrer telle
partie de mon corps et pas telle partie
de mon corps je ne vais jamais franchir
la barrière du réel mais en fait la
tentation de l'argent facile fait que si
un jour vous dit bah je vous donne 50
000 € pour coucher avec toi et ben les
personnes ils vont ça c'est le premier
danger et là où c'est pire que la
prostitution c'est que ça laisse des
traces c'est-à-dire que les gens font
des captures d'écran les gens gardent
des preuves ils s'en servent contre vous
c'est ce qu'on appelle le Revenge porn
et en ce sens c'est encore pire que la
prostitution parce qu'il y a des jeunes
qui ont peut-être fait ça il y a 5 ou 10
ans qui aujourd'hui on souffre
énormément et qui regrette donc c'est
très dangereux on a un témoignage d'une
fille qui fait ça donc juste soyez
vigilants les parents parce qu'en fait
il y a en fait il y a de plus en plus de
jeunes filles et de jeunes garçons qui
le font qu'ils le font qui font des
comptes de paiement à distance et qui
d'avoir gagné beaucoup d'argent et les
parents et les grands-parents encore
moins ne sont pas du tout au courant ils
font ça dans leur chambre tranquillement
donc c'est quand même un fléau important
et on a un témoignage regardez
la plupart des cam girl exerce un de
leurs domicile alors elles sont
installées devant leur PC avec une
webcam et puis à côté elles ont leurs
outils de travail voilà les plateformes
de l'alaskam il y en a des tonnes les
plus grosses reposent sur un système de
diffusion en public c'est à dire que les
filles en fait sont visibles par tout le
monde et elle se dénue
il y a des instruments quand même
c'est bon j'ai rien dit
merci oui
beaucoup d'étudiants et d'étudiantes qui
font ça ils confient que ça fait quand
même un complément de revenu qui n'ont
pas il y a aussi toutes les parties là
de cette population
soyez vigilant et je pense quand même
que là on a la limite quand même et